forscher haben ein super massereiches
schwarzes loch aus dem zentrum einer
galaxie entdeckt nur es war nicht mehr
im zentrum sondern 35 tausend lichtjahre
entfernt um das schwarze loch aus der
mitte der galaxie zu werfen wäre die
gleichzeitige explosion von rund 100
millionen sternen als supernovae
vonnöten gewesen was war also passiert
darum geht es jetzt weiter herzlich
willkommen bei richtungswechseln bei der
beobachtung des basars 1386 also dem
extrem hellen kern einer galaxie was die
forscher eine spektakuläre entdeckung
aktionen um marko kovac vom space
telescope science institute in baltimore
in den usa mussten feststellen dass bei
dieser galaxie einfach gar nichts mehr
stimmt ihr kern war nämlich gar nicht
mehr erkennen
das zentrum der galaxie war 35 tausend
lichtjahre von dem ort entfernt wird
eigentlich sein sollte und schießt
weiter mit einer geschwindigkeit von 7 6
millionen kilometern pro stunde vom
zentrum weg in alle verrückt was kann
dieses die ganze ausgelöst haben es ist
eine unglaubliche kräfte gewesen sein
die das schwarze loch mit mehr als einer
milliarde sonnenmassen so beschleunigt
haben eigentlich etwas undenkbares sind
die forscher einem neuen geheimnis des
weltalls auf der spur
eine riesige unbekannte kraft die alles
bisher dagewesene in den schatten stellt
ja ein bisschen ist es so und die gerade
entdeckten gravitationswellen liefern
die erklärung für diese kosmische
katastrophe
die forscher haben tatsächlich eine
erklärung für das unerklärliche gefunden
demnach war diese galaxie früher mal
zwei galaxien diese beiden der aktien
sind verschmolzen um mit ihren kernen
ist was ja unglaubliches geschehen sind
nämlich nicht auf einmal zusammen
gestoßen sondern haben sich erstmal
immer schneller umkreis genauso wie das
ereignis das die entdeckung der
kavitation wellen ermöglicht hat auch
hier hatten sich zwei schwarze löcher
immer schneller umkreist und dabei
gravitationswellen verbrannt genau das
ist hier auch passiert mit einem
unterschied die beiden schwarzen löcher
unterschieden sich deutlich in ihrer
größe entschuldigung
das hatten ein paar von euch moniert
weil ich immer größe sage eine größe hat
bei einem warten noch ja nur der
ereignishorizont also die grenze ab der
alles unweigerlich in der schwarze loch
gezogen wird und wo jenseits dieser
grenze nicht mehr aus dem loch
entweichen kann außer natürlich der
hawking strahlung aber das ist ein
anderes thema ansonsten ist die masse in
einem schwarzen loch jagd zu einer
singularität zusammengestürzt also einem
unendlich kleinen punkt und hat somit
keine größe diese beiden schwarzen
löcher hatten also eine unterschiedliche
mache und dementsprechend waren die
ausgelösten gravitationswellen in eine
richtung immer stärker als in die andere
richtung als die löcher dann
verschmolzen ersetzten diese gerichteten
gravitationswellen denn dann
entstandenen einen schwarzen loch einen
riesigen schritt und es liegt jetzt
vollkommen losgelöst in die weiten des
alls fliegt es dabei durch die scheibe
der galaxie also durch die ganzen
sternensysteme wird es sich unzählige
davon einverleiben und noch größer
werden also in der galaxie möchte ich
jetzt mit unserem sonnensystem nicht
sein wie jetzt dann bei unserem
16-jährigen forscher wird diese
katastrophe wieder viele fragen aus für
mich vor allem eine passiert so etwas
öfter da können ja immer mehr schwarze
löcher durch all fliegen womit wir
wieder bei meinem lieblingsthema der
dunkle materie werden super schwange
vielmehr wenn ihr euch für dunkle
materie gelöst spielen schwarze löcher
eine rolle interessiert dann vielleicht
unter umständen durch möchte wirklich
nicht betteln ich unbedingt vermeiden
ich könnte dir dann auf dieses video
klicken und wenn er nicht mehr verpassen
wollt dann drückt mir ein abo auf auge
und dafür hier klicken und vergesst
nicht mehr einen auf die von glocke zu
geben bislang bleibt dran